tomorrow is the annual Summerlin Council
patriotic parade and this is from video
from years past this year there are more
than 70 floats including the eight news
now float featuring The Super Ball and
some of our on-air anchors both the
governor lieutenant governor will be on
hand to kick things off Vegas golden
knights Nick Hague and Zach White Cloud
will be on the Vegas golden knights
float we will begin our live coverage
tomorrow morning at five in the morning
join us parade starts at nine but you
want to get there early to grab a good
spot because it is very busy and our own
Sherry Brian Mercedes and JC will be the
MCs